Alhamdulillah.
[Silence]
forch.
Allah subhanahu wa ta'ala says in the
closing verses of
he says
so what are they waiting for what he's
speaking about here who he is speaking
of the or speaking about the
disbelievers those who have disbelieved
now notice where this verse is placed
it's placed at the very end of surah
Surah
focuses very heavily on the reputation
of all of the superstitions
and all of the disbeliefs of the people
of Jahyah. All of them. It focuses on
the reputation of the shabuet
of the mushrien, the idoltors, the
disbelievers in general, the people of
the book, the Jews, the Christians, all
of them are responded to and refuted in
this in this chapter. Even false
prophets,
even the slightest of superstitions,
they're all refuted generally or
specifically in this surah.
So all of the arguments have been
responded to. Notice all of the
arguments have been responded to
and
was all revealed together at one time.
It's a very large surah, very long
surah. Yet it all came down all at once.
Abbas
says about
[Silence]
he says
was revealed in Mecca all at once.
during the night and it was accompanied
by 70,000 in some wordings of this
narration
a
was mentioned
mo is a parade in Arabic
it was followed and accompanied by a
parade
of angels angels
70,000
in number all making and
of Allah as they accompanied this surah
could we just take a moment here to
appreciate the magnitude of that our
prophet sallallah alaii wasallam is
sitting in Mecca when suddenly
the door
to The sama is opened and from it
descends Gibl.
With him is a parade of 70,000
angels.
And he could hear them murmuring
with and
of Allah as they're coming. They're
accompanying this surah. Subhan Allah.
Allahbarahill.
Allahbar.
Alhamdulillah. As they all arrive
in front of the prophet sallallah.aii
wasallam and then Jirel begins to recite
to him what?
I mean just imagine the image.
But what does this tell us about?
It tells us that
is one of the most majestic and
important chapters of the Quran. As a
matter of fact, when surah was revealed,
it was literally a gamecher.
It changed the course of history, this
chapter, and it changed the position and
the the it it marked a turning point or
a milestone for the da of Islam in
Mecca.
So at the end of this chapter, so all
has been responded to, all the arguments
that have been posited,
all the arguments that the prophet
sallallah.aii wasallam was faced with,
why this and why that and what about
this person who claims to be a prophet
and what about that one? All of these
arguments were responded to inah.
At the very end of that, Allah wraps
up and says,
"What are they waiting for?"
Meaning, here's the truth. This is the
truth. Everyone has been responded to.
Why are you not now following and
becoming Muslim? What are they waiting
for? Are they waiting for the angels to
come to them or your Lord to come
himself or some of the major signs of
your Lord? Now, let's take a pause there
at these three things. He mentions the
angels. He mentions the arrival of
Allah. And he mentions the arrival of
some of the major miracles and signs of
Allah. These are three different events.
Notice these are three different events.
They share a commonality.
What is what do these three events have
in common? The first one is the angels
coming. The angels here meaning the
angels of death.
Because is it just one angel of death?
Huh?
So the angels
when a person dies it's not just one
angel that comes yes they have a leader
a commander who is the angel of death
but they this commander has many many
many angels under his command
just Mik
he has many angels under his command to
regulate the rain and the wind and all
of these things. Likewise, Gi has many
angels under his command, right?
And the angel of death has many angels
under his command. In the narration of
the prophet sallallah.aii alaihi
wasallam said that when a person dies,
the first thing they see is the angels
of death descend and surround him as far
as the eye can see.
So as a person gets ready to to die,
they see suddenly the rooms start to
fill up the room, the area, the field,
the valley, the prairie, wherever they
are dying.
But as far as their eye can see, all
they can see are the angels of death
coming to prepare his soul for
collection for harvest. Right? Our
souls, what are our souls? What are our
lives? But a planted seed,
your life and my life and your life.
Every one of us, our heart is what? A
seed. It's been planted on the earth
here, right?
Allah gives us this imagery in
he says
we grow
on the earth just the rest of the
trees and vegetation around us grow and
then harvest comes.
Correct?
We are growing into either being a
believer or a disbeliever. May Allah
subhanahu wa ta'ala make us all of the
utmost of believers and make our day and
time of death the best day and time of
our existence.
So we are a planted crop
and we grow and time for harvest comes.
Who does Allah send to harvest us?
He sends the angel of death.
And so the angel of death comes after
the angels of death come to prepare the
soul.
They come to prepare this person for
death.
And when they are preparing this person
for death
when it is ready and ripe for harvest,
the angel of death comes and he extracts
the soul.
He extracts the soul easily and gently
or extracts the soul viciously and
violently.
And the angels around him are holding a
shroud made of light or made of fire.
And when he takes this soul, he places
it in the shroud.
The shroud of light or the shroud of
fire.
So Allah here in this verse says,
Huh?
[Silence]
What are they waiting for? Are they
waiting for the arrival of the angels,
meaning to take their souls in death? Or
are they awaiting the arrival of your
Lord?
When will Allah arrive
to judge?
Huh? The day of judgment. So the arrival
of your Lord is the most significant
thing that will happen on what day? The
day of judgment. So here he mentions
first an individual's death. The second
one he mentions the day of judgment when
the whole world will die and be
resurrected
and then Allah will arrive to judge.
And that is or some of the major signs
and miracles of your lord. Then he
speaks about these miracles. He says
when the major signs of your lord
arrive,
no soul
that believes after witnessing these
signs
will be accepted by Allah. Their belief
will not be accepted.
nor any soul that was a believer but did
nothing fruitful with their belief.
No more turning over a new leaf.
Turning over a new leaf, turning over a
new page, a new chapter in your life,
the door of Toba being opened in the
west. All of this what closes. So what
do these three things have in common?
Inahkari
Abu
was told by the prophet Sam.
Listen to this narration. He said
they were watching the sunset. He was
with the prophet sallallahu alaihi
wasallam. He said,
he said, "Do you know where this sun
goes when it sets? After it sets,
he said,
What?
[Silence]
forch.
So the prophet sallallah.aii wasallam is
speaking to him. He says, "Do you know
where this sun goes when it sets?" He
said, "Allah and his messenger knows
best." He said, "It continues until it
falls in prostration
under the throne of Allah."
At the throne of Allah. Under the throne
of Allah.
And upon prostrating it then asks
permission
from Allah to continue in its journey
and Allah grants it permission and it
continues until it rises from the east
and so it goes.
He said on one day it will set for in
the west and fall prostrate under the
throne of Allah
and seek permission
to continue on its path
and Allah will not grant it permission
to continue
and instead he will command it saying go
back the way you came.
And at that moment the sun will then
rise from the west.
And when the sun rises from the west,
the prophet continues, "When the sun
rises from the west,
when the people see it, the people of
earth, they will all believe
simultaneously.
[Silence]
All
speech. for
[Silence]
Edge.
when in the Arabic language you say all
of them
means together simultaneously at the
same time. The prophet says that when
the people see the sun rise from the
west, all of them will immediately
believe simultaneously.
Everyone will believe immediately.
The prophet sallallah.aii alaihi
wasallam commented and said, "And that
is when
no soul that was not a believer prior
will be accepted as a believer after
witnessing this. When the people see the
sunrise from the west, all of them will
believe. And anyone who was not a
believer prior to that, his belief will
not be accepted."
Now, here's the question. What do these
three
times have? What do these three
happenings have in common? Why does
Allah mention these three things
together? He mentions death. He mentions
the day of judgment. He mentions the sun
rising from the west. What do these
three events have in common?
Huh?
[Arabic recitation]
All three events
share something in common. What is that?
Those events,
they
cause a person to believe in spite of
himself. Everyone believes during those
three events.
Everyone believes. Is there an atheist
when he dies? No. When the angels show
up and they ripping his soul out of his
body, is he still debating on whether or
not there is a creator? No. They all
believe at that point. Everybody repents
when they die. Everybody repents when
Allah arrives to judge. Everyone
believes and repents when the sun rises
from the west. But is that repentance?
Is that belief of any value at that
point? No. Why?
Isn't that what Allah said? Those are
the rules, right? No one can be
compelled to believe, right? Well, those
those events compel everyone to believe.
You don't want to be forced to believe,
sure. But when you see something that is
irrefutable
and you believe those are the rules
we're going by.
And so nothing
is unique at the moment of death. No
one's repentance is unique at the moment
of death. No one's repentance is unique
at the moment of judgment. No one's
repentance is unique at the arrive at
the sun rising from the west. Those
things are not unique happening. The
belief that those things illicit is not
unique. It's not something that a person
chooses consciously and fights his
demons in order to do
right. Even a shan andl himself cannot
explain those three things away.
So there's nothing unique about belief
at that point and that is why it is not
accepted. The prophet sallall.aii
wasallam tells us that when the sun
rises from the west the door of Toba
will be closed.
Some of the mention the meaning the
predecessors the the right. It's
actually the words of
he mentions that
the door of repentance is in the west
and when the sun rises from it it will
be closed forever.
Just imagine
if the sun r rises from the west what
would happen on this earth
but then the scientists are telling us
well the the earth's gravitational pull
and the magnetics and also the solar
flares and also that the earth's
rotation is slowing you know very little
and it's eventually okay Great. This is
not an explanation,
right? The sun will rise from the west.
And by the way, it won't just
immediately rise from the west. It will
disappear for a while. It'll be gone.
Meaning nighttime
will fall upon humanity and it'll be a
very long night. People will wake up.
The believers will wake up
for salah and find that it's still dark
out.
They'll wake up for fud and find that
it's still dark out.
There will be a total blackout. Where'd
the sun go?
People will start to panic.
Chaos will ensue because the sun is
missing.
And then after this long night, it's not
mentioned how long this night is, but it
is mentioned that this night is long
enough that we will have to make our
five daily prayers during that night
based on averages.
We'll have to approximate when would
have been if the sun was up today and
make at that time.
Asia. And then finally after this long
lull,
this global lull,
the sun will reappear.
But this time it will be rising from the
west.
And when the people see that,
they will immediately
stare,
gawking,
starruck at the heavens and they will
believe all at the same time
simultaneously.
But no one's belief is going to be
accepted at that point.
What's that?
How close is the day of judgment from
that point? Very close.
Probably years, if not months.
But there's some other events that will
happen after the sun rises from the
west. But people will believe. It won't
be accepted. People will either have
been a believer or a disbeliever by that
point. Could you imagine
believing in Allah in the last day,
but you can't believe now? it's not
accepted. And you're watching a p the
these these poor damned souls watching
the clock knowing that when it strikes
midnight, they will go to hell and there
is nothing they can do to stop it.
But that is a conscious choice that they
made for themselves.
Now
this verse has
another dimension of explanation
and in that explanation we will
understand why the deed will exist. That
was your question yesterday, right? Why
this test?
And it has to do with this verse.
Inshallah, we will discuss that
tomorrow.
Foreham.
[Silence]
That's a really good question.
We'll talk about it.